going to the theater and sitting in the  room with a bunch of strange events  seeing all these beautiful images that  we shot in that scale is like you  selling me way to really experience the  film built very wide big set and seeing  them on IMAX you're just seeing a level  of detail I'm actually getting  everything and it's it's pretty special  that movie like The Mummy is meant to be  seen in IMAX later it's meant to be seen  in a big experience you know the mummies  coming out at you and everything is  terrifying I think I'm not gonna add  such an incredible weight to our movie  in this you'll be able to absorb the  scenes and feel the pace and the energy  and it's going to be the ride of a  lifetime  you